All right. Good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Steve Forman, and I'm from the City of Hope Comprehensive Cancer Center
in Los Angeles.
It
has been my honor to serve as the chair of this year's selection committee for the
AACR Joseph H. Burkenau Award for
Outstanding Achievement in Clinical Cancer Research.
This award was established in 1996 in collaboration with Bristol
Myers.
It's meant to award investigators whose work has
profoundly advanced clinical cancer research and improved patient
care. The award commemorates the late Joseph Burkenau,
who was a past president and honorary member of AACR.
His career spanned five decades and was a true pioneer in
helping establish, at that time, chemotherapy as a transformative treatment for
cancer, and was awarded the Lasker Prize for
his work, particularly in Burkitt
lymphoma. This year's honoree is a
physician-scientist whose work has reshaped cancer diagnosis and treatment.
The 2026 AACR Joseph Burkenau Award for Outstanding Achievement
in Clinical Cancer Research is being presented to Dr. Luis Diaz Jr.
Dr. Diaz serves as the Solid Tumor Oncology Division Head and
Grayer Family Chair at Memorial Sloan Kettering in New York,
where he leads the clinical care of cancer patients across 10 disease
programs while conducting his own translational research that has
reshaped cancer diagnosis and therapy.
And I can speak very personally of the idea that there's not a
day that doesn't go by that some of the work that you do, we use
throughout our clinics at the City of Hope and in my own practice in
particular. He's widely recognized for his groundbreaking work in
tumor genomics, circulating tumor DNA, immunotherapy, which
has, as I said, revolutionized the way we detect, monitor, and actually
take care of people with cancer.
Dr. Diaz has been a leader in the development of circulating tumor DNA
as a non-invasive biomarker, demonstrating its ability to provide
comprehensive genetic profiling that allows us to do
earlier intervention, follow a patient more precisely and more
carefully over time.
He has led pivotal studies that establish checkpoint immunotherapy as an effective
treatment for patients with a particular type of genetic background, where their
cancer has mismatch repair deficient or microsatellite
instability-high cancers, making them extraordinarily susceptible
to immune recognition and intervention.
These studies supported the first FDA approval of a therapy based on a tumor's
molecular features rather than its tissue
of origin,
a milestone that really has redefined the meaning of what we refer to as
precise oncology.
His discoveries have been translated into clinical innovations.
He's co-founded several companies. Dr.
Diaz's leadership extends across the academic oncology community.
He serves as editor-in-chief of the AACR journal, "Cancer
Discovery," previously served on the AACR Board of Directors,
and was inducted as a fellow of the AACR Academy in 2022.
He's been on the National Cancer Advisory Board, where he continues to
contribute to shaping the national priorities for cancer research in
this country.
Through his work in genomics, diagnostics, and immunotherapy, Dr.
Diaz has advanced clinical research and improved outcomes for patients
worldwide, making him a very appropriate recipient for this
award, as I would say, in mid-career.
It's my honor to introduce the 2026 recipient of the AACR Joseph
Burkenau Award for Outstanding Achievement in Clinical Research, Dr.
Luis A. Diaz Jr.
Thanks so much.
You're very welcome.
Thank you.
Yeah, sure.
Appreciate that.
I appreciate the introduction and many thanks to the AACR, to you, and the
committee for this honor.
It's always a little awkward to get an award as an individual when
all of this work was really done by teams.
And there's an AACR Team Award, I think, that emblemizes a lot of things.
But I thank the committee and the AACR because this is really a reflection
on the teams that work on this work.
I have to work on my disclosures here.
And a bit about Joseph Burkenau. Whenever I look at
these awards, I never spend the time to look up who
the honoree really is or who it's named after.
And I want to just review a little bit who Joseph Burkenau was, and you never
really do it until you get an award like this.
And he actually was a chemotherapy pioneer at Memorial Sloan Kettering, which is
interesting because I work at Memorial Sloan Kettering, and he really helped make
drug treatment a real path
to cancer cure. He organized clinical chemotherapy program at MSK
after World War II, helping define oncology as a distinct medical field and
discipline. He co-developed mercaptopurine, an advanced combination
chemotherapy for leukemia and lymphoma,
helped launch the war on cancer, and shaped modern clinical oncology research,
and won the 1972 Lasker Award.
So I'm going to begin very basic and then dive into where some of
this work really began
to take shape. So how does cancer evolve?
It evolves from a normal tissue, this is a normal colon, to a
pre-malignant lesion, to an invasive lesion, to a metastatic lesion.
If you look histologically, you see the classic changes from a
precancerous adenoma to a large adenoma to an invasive carcinoma.
If you look molecularly, you'll see the acquisition of mutations
in a sequential, organized fashion, and key mutated genes
increase regions of those genes that either activate genes for
proliferation and growth or turn off genes that prevent cell
death.
Interesting thing is that at least in solid tumors, this doesn't occur overnight.
This doesn't occur over a month or two or even a year.
This occurs over a decade or two.And that gives us an opportunity
and has given a lot of people opportunity to think about potentially early
detection because this happens over a time span.
And these mutations are defined by their presence in
either cancer cells or pre-cancer cells called somatic
mutations, and they're absent from the corresponding normal tissues.
And really over the past 30 years, there has been
a
sequencing of tumors from the adults and children, men and women, and
virtually every organism who has a cancer where we
understand the cancer
mutation landscape, and we have a mutational profile that's quite
vast.
And this somatic cancer genome data, so mutations just in the
tumor and not in the corresponding normal tissue, can
be used for a variety of different things.
And my job after my postdoc when I joined a very basic
science lab was, how can you take this information and use it clinically?
And the hope was, one, maybe we'd have a predictive marker.
We'd find a mutation, we marry that with a drug, and you'd cure the
cancer. Really hard to do. And
we have some examples, very hard to do.
Next thing is you could take these mutations and look at
prognosis. And one of the early mutations we discovered was
IDH
in gliomas, and that was a better prognosis than those without IDH
mutations. But two of the areas that I think
we began to think about as a group, and this was when I was at Johns Hopkins,
was could you take these mutations and either use them as diagnostic
tools
in a dynamic way in biofluids, liquid biopsy.
And the other way to look at them was, could these mutations in the
context of an expressed protein be an immune antigen and stimulate the
immune system in a unique way? And so I'll take you primarily through the
immune antigen story,
but there's a vast background and history to the liquid biopsy story as well.
And the immune oncology story really began
with these two papers. I joined a cancer genetics lab
because I never thought the immune system would ever work to treat solid tumor
oncology. And I was very confident in that until these two
papers showed up.
This was checkpoint blockade with Ipi Milab against
CTLA-4 in metastatic melanoma showing response,
and then anti-PD-1. And it wasn't the response in
melanoma or also kidney cancer that surprised me or that
interested me. Those are immunogenic tumors, not surprising at
all. What surprised me and the whole field was we
were starting to see responses in lung cancer, and that was
unique. These tumors are like rocks, and I didn't think the immune system
could at all change the outcome of these patients, and we started to see those
outcomes. So that piqued our interest.
And the laboratory had been focusing a lot
on cancer exome sequencing of solid tumors.
And with work with Bert Vogelstein, Nick Papadopoulos,
and
Nick Papadopoulos, whose sentencing right there we describe
the sequence of a variety of different tumors, liquid tumors, pediatric
tumors, sporadic adult tumors, mutagen-induced tumors,
and then mismatch repair-deficient tumors.
And simply counting the number of mutations from tumor type, you could see there
was a big difference.
And what was interesting to us is that at the time, melanoma and lung cancers,
we found had many more mutations than sporadic tumors.
And these were the tumors that were responding.
So it set up a question which is, could a tumor type with
many more mutations
potentially be more immunogenic?
And so a little bit about mismatch repair-deficient tumors and microsatellite
instability, because they're two sides of the same coin.
Mismatch repair deficiency comes in two forms, a hereditary form called Lynch
syndrome and a sporadic form. With a hereditary form, you inherit
one allele that's inactivated, and you acquire a second allele during
early pre-adenoma development, and then you lose the second allele.
Sporadic, you lose both during oncogenesis.
The hereditary form is rarer than the sporadic form.
And when you have inactivation of mismatch repair, it leads during DNA
replication an inability to recognize and repair
spontaneous mutations, either single base pair mutations or short insertions and
deletions.
And then this leads to
accumulation of mutations, ultramicrosatellites, and then
eventually MSI and TMB. So if you're
mismatch repair deficient on day one,
you're not going to be high TMB the next day.
You're not going to be high TMB the next month.
It's going to take years for that to develop.
Likewise, you're not MSI the day after you are mismatch repair deficient.
You're MSI many months or years later.
So this is a process that accumulates over time.
And taking you a little bit back to the history,
there was a long history in understanding these hereditary mutations, which
gave us the first clues of what mismatch repair deficiency was.
And this is work done by Albert de la Chapelle and one of my mentors, Bert
Vogelstein,
in showing that these familial cancers had widespread
alterations in microsatellites,
and that these microsatellites, when they were altered, are more common
in the familiar form
and frequently altered in the familiar form than the non-familiar form of
mismatch repair deficiency.
And Nick, who I highlighted before was the first to describe
one of the hereditary mutations
that inactivated mismatch repair in Lynch
syndrome.
And then when further looking at these, they found that there was a
hypermutability of these tumors.
And this is back in 1993 when the...
mutations and hypermutability was really
defined by very different tools than we use today.
And so you can see this is about 1993.
In parallel, and this is all happening at Johns Hopkins at the time,
Stan Hamilton, a pathologist, described something that all
pathologists knew.
If you have a patient with a hereditary colon cancer, oftentimes they had a rich
lymphocytic infiltrate. And what he defined were that these mismatch repair
deficient tumors were often inflamed and infiltrated with lymphocytes.
So setting up the stage for an immunogenic response
going on there. So 1994.
Not much happened from 1994 till those two papers came out in
PD-1 blockade. Primarily worked on
identifying and screening for Lynch syndrome for screening purposes,
and there was a lot of work done there, but on the therapeutic angle.
And so the hypothesis that we had when we saw the cancer genomics
work and the immunotherapy responses, primarily in lung cancer,
was if these genomes of mismatch repair tumors had thousands of mutations,
if these mutations happen to be expressed as proteins,
would that induce a foreign-looking tumor to the immune system?
And if that foreignness was controlled by
upregulation of immune checkpoints, could you treat them with immune
checkpoint blockade? We knew they were highly inflamed and could this treatment
with immune checkpoint blockade lead to a very potent antitumor response.
So
when we had this idea,
we were primarily a research lab. We didn't know how to run clinical trials, so we
recruited Yung Li, who was a junior assistant, actually, a newly minted
assistant professor, because she would be the only one that listened to us.
And we didn't have money, we didn't have a drug, but we had now an investigator
and an idea. And we designed this idea
on a whiteboard that we would take colon cancers, the most common tumor type with
mismatch repair deficiency,
and take a cohort that was mismatch repair deficient, take
another cohort of colon cancers that were mismatch repair proficient, and because
mismatch repair deficiency can be found in many other tumor types, we had another
bucket for mismatch repair deficient tumors that were
of any tumor type.
So two things happened during this time after we had the idea.
We went to all the drug companies.
None of the PD-1s were approved at that time, and so we asked, "Would you give the
drug?" And they all said no. But we had a backdoor
through Merck because one of our fellows had recently been hired there, and so
Merck agreed to give us a drug, but we'd have to hold our own IND
on a separate lot,
and they wouldn't pay for it. And so
funding then came from philanthropic groups from across America.
So 500 swimmers jump in the Chesapeake Bay each year, and they
gave us their funds to run this study.
So we had everything in place to run the study.
And I'll tell you one more story. Finding these patients was really hard because no
one tests metastatic patients for mismatch repair deficiency.
So
Hopkins sees a fair number of patients, but not enough to see a lot.
So we had these summer high school students who
want to get into college and get a letter from us.
We had them drive around to all the practices and buy pizza and cookies,
and they tested their metastatic colorectal cancer patients for mismatch repair,
and they sent them into the study. So we initiated this study in
2013.
We took patients who were treatment-refractory,
failed all lines of therapy,
and we gave a fairly high dose of pembrolizumab, 10 milligrams per kilogram every
two weeks. The current dosing is 200 milligrams every three weeks or every six
weeks even.
And we started the study. So when we first started the study, we saw some
remarkable things. This is an example of a common patient that was treated at
baseline in 20 weeks, a normalization of the CEA, which is a circulating
protein biomarker,
and patients were getting better almost immediately.
And when we looked at the radiographic response, mismatch repair deficient tumors,
high tumor mutational burden, MSI-H responded very well.
The proficient colorectal cancers did not respond at all or responded
very poorly.
And this response oftentimes happened incredibly fast.
And early on when we were treating these patients,
we saw things like patients end up in the emergency room, they were going
nauseous, and they were going actually through withdrawal from
removing their pain medications,
which was something that we hadn't seen to date.
Progression-free survival of the initial group was not reached in the mismatch
repair deficient. In the proficient, they progressed very rapidly,
and the overall survival
matched that and was quite good and not reached in the deficient.
In the proficient, the overall survival, median survival, was about six months.
So that was the cohort A and B, the colon cancer and the
comparison between them. And in the other cohort, plus another paper that
we followed up with, we started looking at mismatch repair deficient tumors and
MSI-H tumors of other tumor types.
So not just colon, even though it's the most common, but endometrial, gastric,
cholangio, pancreas, small intestine, and even to some of these rarer tumors where
we found mismatch repair deficiency.
And when we looked at tumors where more than 10 patients were treated,
they all responded quite well. And this is overall survival.
And the median survival was not reached for the majority of these tumor types, with
the exception of two, gliomas and pancreatic cancer.
We still, to this date, don't know why they do so poorly.
But for by and large, it was curative in more than half of patients who were
treated with this approach.
So because of this work and because of the publication in
2015, there was breakthrough status in colon cancer and an
approval in treatment-refractory colon cancer.
But then soon thereafter, in 2017, when we began to publish the
tumor responses in non-colon cancer, we received the
first tumor-agnostic concept and FDA approvalSo that concept
didn't exist beforehand, and this was really the first approval that kind of
catapulted this concept into
drug development in a way that hadn't been done before.
But what was interesting is that it no longer looked at the tumor of where it was
born, but it looked at the tumor based on its molecular identity,
and you had a treatment that was approved now based on that.
And so since then, there have been other approvals, both with immune checkpoint
blockade and small molecules that use this tumor-agnostic concept.
So those were advanced tumors, and what I walked you through
was
metastatic tumors that were treatment refractory, PAN tumors, not just
colon cancer. What I didn't show you is now for first-line for many tumor
types, endometrial cancer, and colon cancer, there's approvals.
And so that area is kind of covered, and that has
actually gotten better with the combination of PD-1 blockade with CTLA-4 blockade,
and those response rates and cure rates are even higher.
But what about other scenarios? And one scenario that
was very interesting to us was microscopic residual tumors.
And it really pivots off the idea of minimal residual disease.
And what is minimal residual disease?
Well, the folks in heme malignancies understand this concept very well.
This is a concept that is really coming to vogue in solid
tumor oncology, which is following definitive therapy, so
tumor resection
or definitive chemotherapy, radiation, or in some cases,
immunotherapy. The tumor's removed, and you have no idea
if your patient's cured or not. No idea.
And you have to wait to see if the tumor's going to recur or not.
There are some risk stratifiers, but they're all not very good.
So the concept was, is there a way to measure something immediately after surgery
that could define someone as cured or not cured?
And the idea for this started in about 2007.
This is one of our graduate students, Carlo Rago,
where we were first looking at fragments of DNA, or we were looking for a way to
monitor tumor growth in mice
without having to just... Because we thought calipers were very inaccurate.
If we had metastatic models that were very inaccurate to measure growth, or
bioluminescence was just coming into vogue.
So could you do a p***k to the tail vein, get a drop of blood,
dilute that in EDTA, separate the cell-free DNA,
and then measure that, this is a xenograft for human
DNA,
and this one line one element that
is sequences exclusive to the mouse, and could you track the tumor
growth and response of therapies?
And we did a simple experiment to look at this.
So we looked at human line
one. We created a small amplicon, and we could measure that in mice.
And so as the tumor grew, it increased in size.
But if you cut out the tumor,
it went down to zero, and it went down to zero almost immediately.
And so you can see here the tumor is growing.
We resect it, and it goes down to zero. It goes down to zero.
The half-life of these fragments were about two hours.
And so it set up the next question.
Could we look at circulating mutant DNA in humans?
And so there were some techniques that were developed at this time, and
this is the first example of that. So this was published in 2008,
and Frank Dio is the first author.
What we did here was take a technique called beaming, and this is looking at a
single mutation
by single
base extension using a technique that is resolved by
flow cytometry. And you see the wild-type fragments in green and
the mutant fragments there in red.
And you see after a curative resection, day one, day 42, and day
244.
And at day one, you see the mutant fragments almost disappear.
And at day 42, the CT scan's negative when they see the medical
oncologist, but then the patient recurs at day 244, and you see the
mutant fragments have increased.
And so what we were seeing here is the evolution of minimal residual disease.
It's not visible by the surgeon, not visible by radiology,
not detectable by any other methodology, but we were able to track
the tumor recurrence very early. Now, the half-life of these
fragments is two hours. That was measured at 24 hours.
There should be no circulating tumor DNA at 24 hours.
We knew at day one that patient was going to recur.
There was residual disease because what creates this is cells that
are constantly turning over, or cancer cells in the body.
And when we looked at a large number of patients, or a small number of patients,
but in the larger number of patients, we saw those with detectable ctDNA all
recurred, and those with undetectable ctDNA did not recur.
So for us, setting up the concept of minimal residual disease
defined by circulating tumor DNA.
So defining who's cured and who's not cured immediately after surgery.
And so
since that paper was published, and it's taken a long time, there's probably been
50 to 100 patients, papers published using minimal
residual disease measured by ctDNA to prognosticate
recurrence or not recurrence after surgery in virtually every tumor type.
And what we know is that if you're circulating tumor DNA positive after surgery,
the likelihood you're going to recur is in 90%.
It's not as good as if you're negative.
If you're negative, the likelihood that you won't recur
is still not very predictive.
But the reason I brought this up in this talk about immunotherapy is because we
wanted to bring this concept forward
in looking at the effectiveness of mismatched paired blockade in the minimal
residual disease setting
and combine that with the predictive value of circulating tumor DNA in
minimal residual disease.
And so the questions were
can an intervention with PD-1 blockade tumors eradicate minimal residual disease
detected by ctDNA? And two, could you alter the
natural history of disease? Since you're positive after surgery you're going to
recur, can we alter that natural history?
And so we conceived it with Yelena Janjigian,
and this is not an easy study.
And you've got to beA workhorse to get a study like
this done. And so we took patients that underwent an
R0 surgical resection. That means clean margins.
The tumors were sequenced,
and if they were mismatched or deficient and they underwent standard of care
therapy afterwards, then they underwent a ctDNA analysis.
If they were positive, they randomized a pembrolizumab or placebo.
If they were negative, we just observed them.
And so we had to close the placebo arm.
Why do you think?
We started this in 2019. We had a placebo-controlled trial.
We recruited one patient.
Accrual was challenging for two reasons.
Patients and doctors were very reticent to refer patients to a ctDNA
positive trial with a placebo arm.
If you're going to recur,
no one wants to go on that placebo arm. And so it was very slow to recur.
And second, the rate of ctDNA positivity was rare.
And what you're going to find in these ctDNA-directed MRD
studies or minimal residual disease studies is that's always going to be the case.
And if you look at all the prospective ones that are going now, it's very rare to
find a positive population. So we closed the placebo arm in
2020, and we continued enrollment through 2023.
And so we closed the placebo arm, and then we were off to the races.
So the second thing is, these were the early days.
These were before Natera existed.
These were when there were large panels.
So we decided to use any panel, and we used what's called a tumor-informed
approach. The tumor sequenced, and then we looked for the
mutations found in the tumors that were sequenced in the plasma to tell us if
something's positive or not. Very sensitive.
And what we found that is actually we could use any assay to define who was
positive and who was negative.
And so Yelena and her team screened 174 patients
that were mismatched or deficient,
and they're screened with ctDNA after standard of care therapy,
25 were positive and 125 were negative.
So I'm going to start with the negative patients. What do you think they look like?
They were negative and just observed. They did quite well.
Not perfect,
and newer assays, that curve would be better, but it wasn't
perfect, right? So some patients recurred.
What if you were ctDNA positive, because we had some, and they did not receive
anti-PD-1?
They did super poorly, and they progressed quite rapidly.
What if you were ctDNA positive and you received anti-PD-1?
So it was closer to the patients who were ctDNA
negative and just observed. And so a couple of things.
So these patients were treated for six months.
I think a longer duration of treatment would see a better response.
And I think that a better assay would actually probably find patients slightly
earlier in their recurrence. But nonetheless, this kind of proves a
point that not only can you identify minimal residual disease, but you
can intervene and change that natural history.
So the big picture with minimal residual disease, and most assays are adequate for
seeing improvements, we're going to see improvements in the sensitivity.
Detection of the MRD negative population will get better, so we can begin
to remove adjuvant therapy going forward.
We'll improve lead time recurrence, and we can begin to
study the adjuvant space with smaller populations
or moderate-sized populations relative to the current adjuvant studies, which take
thousands of patients. And I think that's going to be a big improvement in
studying the adjuvant therapeutics.
So
we talked about metastatic patients, we talked about the adjuvant setting,
and one thing when I was reading about Dr.
Burchenal is that he really believed cancer, like infections, could be cured
by rational multidrug or even single-drug therapy guided by careful trials
rather than fatalism. At the time,
no one liked chemotherapy, right?
And they thought chemotherapy was a terrible thing.
And obviously back then, the chemotherapy is very different than what we have now.
But he had a formal training in tropical medicine
after World War II, and his mindset was you could
cure these systemic diseases or even these localized diseases with chemotherapy.
So
we had shown some of that today, but I'm going to show you a little bit more.
And I'm going to move on to early-stage cancers.
This is one of the patients that we treated.
And so early-stage cancer. So
I removed the background slide here on rectal cancer, but one of the things
that is always troubling when you have an early-stage patient is even though you
can cure a patient,
if that tumor sits in an organ
where that curative resection is life-altering,
like in the esophagus or in the stomach or in the bladder or in the
rectum, there is going to be a life-altering change to that patient,
even though we cured them. And in rectal cancer, it's one of those cases where
you not only deliver chemotherapy and radiation and then
surgical resection of the rectum, but in a large number of patients, they have an
ostomy,
there's sexual dysfunction, GU dysfunction,
and that's lifelong. And so we designed a study with
Andrea Sercik where we took early-stage, locally advanced rectal
cancers, and we took patients that were mismatched or deficient,
treated them with six months of PD-1 blockade,
and then evaluated them to see if
we were going to go forward with standard of care therapy or not.
And if there was residual disease, we went with standard of care therapy with
chemotherapy, then radiation and surgery.
With every project, there's a moment where the project
goes from, "Oh, this will be another neoadjuvant or another type of
therapy or project that's more standard, or one that can potentially,
if you're lucky, it can be a world-class alt change." And
Andrea felt very strongly that if the patients had a complete response,
she didn't want to force them to have surgery.
Because could you imagine? You get treated, you have a complete response,
and then you remove the rectum. And so we decided to put this
arm in. If the patient has a complete clinical response, which was a paradigm that
was understood before with chemotherapy and radiation,
that they couldGo forward with non-operative management.
And so this was the first patient treated,
and you see there a large tumor in the rectum visible by MRI and PET.
At six weeks, the tumor has quite a good response.
And then at three months, six months, and then throughout 24 months,
the tumor's disappeared. The MRI is normalized, and so is the PET scan.
First patient, bulky T4 tumor,
positive lymph nodes, complete clinical response.
And then the subsequent 13 patients all had the same thing.
The tumors melted away after six months of therapy, and there was
no visible tumor
by imaging, by pathology,
by visual inspection,
and the patients all did quite well.
So what resulted from that is none of those patients required
chemotherapy, none of them required radiation, and none of them required
surgery,
which was remarkable, and I think probably one of the first times that's happened
in oncology.
But the question was next, could this extend beyond rectal cancer?
Because as we know, these tumors occur that are mismatch repair deficient beyond
the rectum.
And so the question is, could we go forward with non-operative management in those
tumors?
And what's the durability of this?
Is this just the tumors disappear and they come right back, or do they stay away?
And so we designed the same study, but with tumors from anywhere else in the body.
And we accrued patients that were not only rectal cancer, but
throughout other organs in the body.
And we really wanted to emphasize on tumors where the surgery was really
life altering.
And so we enrolled 124 patients.
At the time of publication, 117 were evaluable,
and 103 completed treatment. And we had a cohort of rectal cancer patients,
49, and
54 non-rectal cancer patients.
This is
pretty remarkable.
Thirty-five percent of patients had no adverse events.
I think most of us could go to the gym and trigger
alteration that would be toxicity,
but 35% had none. And that's pretty remarkable, and that sets up
another scenario for down the road.
And the toxicity was quite minimal.
So when we looked at the rectal cancer cohort, all 49 had a complete
clinical response, and all went for non-operative management,
so 100%.
And in terms of recurrence-free survival, we've been following these patients for a
while in the range from five months to five years.
And this median follow-up here is quite well, and 96 were recurrence-free at two
years.
In terms of the non-rectal cohort,
we had 35 with complete clinical response and 19 with incomplete
responses.
In the complete clinical response, even though the tumor was gone, two patients
opted for surgery,
human nature,
and 33 went for non-operative management.
In the incomplete clinical responses, 16 went for
surgery, three did not. Again, human nature, they
refused surgery despite having tumor left,
which I find interesting.
But here we see heterogeneity in the response.
So in urothelial cancers, they all responded completely.
Hepatobiliary,
pancreatic biliary, they all responded well. Colon, a little bit less well.
Gastric, a little bit less well. And then GI junction, EG, small bowel, and then
endometrium, prostate, not responding as well.
Small numbers, but framing the idea and the
concept that we could take these tumors
that were mismatch or deficient and maybe avoid surgery in a large
majority of them because they respond so well to immune checkpoint blockade.
So 85% were recurrence-free at two years.
And so going forward, and if you fast-forward to the future,
how do you bring this to the general population of
oncologists and surgeons, and how do you track this?
And I think one of the ways to track this that's quite effective and quite
sensitive,
is using circulating tumor DNA. What we found was that in complete responses, you
see normalization of circulating tumor DNA.
By the end of treatment, those that were CT negative at the time,
no longer had tumor, and they had complete responses.
Incomplete responses, you see this chaotic drop in circulating
tumor DNA. Not all of them are cured.
And these are tumor remains after immune checkpoint blockade.
And even in the recurrences, you see again, the persistence of circulating tumor
DNA despite having a complete response.
This is just another way of looking at it.
The complete responses go to zero by six months or end of treatment.
The incomplete responses and recurrences have persistent circulating tumor DNA.
So this may be a tool we can use to track who can get non-operative
management and who can't.
And when you look at more traditional modalities like imaging and endoscopies,
not only are they slow to define a complete clinical response,
but they're not as specific or sensitive.
And the earliest ways you can really get this is by a biopsy of the tissue
itself, where the tumor bed is, or circulating tumor DNA.
So I think circulating tumor DNA has some promise here.
So future directions. So based on this data,
I think there's going to be a massive reduction in cancer surgeries in the next
five years.
But I think there's going to be more.
I think there's going to be the possibility of therapeutic cancer prevention.
And I'll show you some clues to why we think this is possible. So immunoprevention.
So there
are 1.5 million Lynch syndrome patients in the US currently.
These are patients who harbor the risk but not all have cancer.
The risk of secondary primary malignancy after the first one is 4% per mean
observation years.
And risk varies by germline genotype.
So the question we had was,
could PD-1 blockade prevent cancer?And
we
formulated two questions. One is, could it impact polyp formation?
And the second is, could it delay
cancer or tumor formation? And this is work that we worked on with Sophia
Stadler, Emily Herald,
and this
brought this together quite nicely.
So at Memorial, they had a registry of 837 Lynch syndrome
patients. Most of these had
cancer. Six hundred and sixty-five did not receive
immune checkpoint blockade, but 172 did.
And so first question, would immune checkpoint blockade alter polyp
formation in Lynch syndrome patients?
And so we didn't see a difference in those that received immune checkpoint blockade
or not,
in terms of baseline incidence of polyps,
or the adenomas per colonoscopy. So answering the question to us
that no, immune checkpoint blockade did not impact polyp formation.
Now, if we were smart, we would have known the answer to this before we even asked
the question. Most polyps in mismatch repair deficient tumors or patients with
Lynch syndrome are MSS.
And so they're not classically immunogenic by our criteria.
But what about cancer?
And so we looked at patients who were at high risk, and this was actually an
observation made by Benoit Rousseau.
And these are patients that did not receive immune checkpoint blockade.
And this is a cumulative incidence of cancer in these patients.
And these are patients that had one or two cancers previously.
But what if you received immune checkpoint blockade? What could happen?
Well, there was a dramatic reduction in the incidence of cancer in these patients
as a secondary event after the primary cancers.
And so setting up the stage that while we couldn't inhibit polyp
formation, we can maybe prevent cancer from developing
in these patients.
And this was a fairly long time after the administration of immune
checkpoint blockade in these patients, so there's quite a long effect with earlier
treatment.
And so this is just another way of looking at it.
Those that receive immune checkpoint blockade versus those that don't, there's a
greater than 80% reduction in the incidence of cancer as a preventative
approach in a retrospective evaluation.
Tells us a little bit about the biology as well.
Normal tissue, typically non-immunogenic.
Premalignant tissue, adenoma in this case, were non-immunogenic.
They weren't cleared by anti-PD-1.
But given the history in early stage mismatch repair deficient tumors,
highly immunogenic, and they become a little less immunogenic once they become
metastatic.
And we have some clues here that I think that I didn't highlight specifically,
but if you look at three different compartments, the distant
metastasis, the lymph node bed around the tumor, and the
primary tumor itself,
the primary tumor itself responds beautifully.
You can clear that primary tumor
fairly easily with immune checkpoint blockade if you're mismatch repair deficient.
The metastasis, you'll clear about 50% to 60% of the time.
The lymph node, somewhere in between.
So these different microenvironments respond very differently
when you're thinking about cure
than individual regions.
So in summary about prevention, it doesn't inhibit polyp formation, but it does
slow tumor development, especially in high-risk patients.
And the data all suggests that immunogenicity develops over time
and in different compartments in the body.
This may open the door for immunoprevention.
So one study that we're about to
launch is a randomized study in Lynch syndrome patients of PD-1
blockade versus placebo.
And we're just working out some of the details here, but I think that this could
have a big impact in immunoprevention for this population.
And I think that we're going to be seeing a much
larger amount of preventative studies across the board for cancers, just not
in Lynch syndrome, but across the board.
So therapeutic cancer prevention, I think, is another future direction.
And so what's the third one? The third one is cancer re-engineering.
And what do I mean by that? And I'm not going to talk a lot about this, but the
current therapeutic paradigm is passive.
Patient comes to our door,
they have a genetic alteration, and we treat them.
So we're rolling the dice when the patient walks in the door.
They have no control of it. We have no control of it.
It's whatever's in front of us. And so the tumor
plus target, we give a certain therapy, and we wait for therapy response.
What if we did something different?
What if we give a therapy to hack the tumor, to create a target,
and then treat based on a target that we will the tumor to have,
and induce the therapy response based on what we're trying to do?
And so,
the hypothesis that we have is that can you use tailored
chemical mutagenesis to induce antitumor immunity, and by
chemically altering DNA to the desired genotype leading
to immunogenicity. And there's a couple of barriers that people
put in front of us when we discuss this concept.
One is this random mutagenesis will lead to subclonal architecture and will this
be immunogenic? And the systemic and tumor viability
immunogenications.
The good news is that we have some data,
and most of it's published now, but we found agents that
can mutagenically alter the genomes of these tumors and
create them to be immunogenic.
The bad news is, I won't be presenting it here.
This will be presented tomorrow at the Dharma Master Gen Thai
Symposium, where we have three talks where there is
a chemically alteration of
the genetics of a tumor to induce immunogenicity.
And I think that will be very interesting if you guys want to attend.
So I'm going to conclude.
I think we can cure systemic disease and local disease in the spirit of
Joseph Brekkenaw's vision that cancer could be treated much like an infection.
We can do it in more than 50% of patients with mismatch repair metastatic patients.
And in patients at earlier stages, I think that numbers are going to be much
higher. And with future developments, I think we're going to get very close to
100%.Microsatellite instability as a therapeutic target is a marriage
really between cancer genetics and cancer immunotherapy and is a
founding example of tumor-agnostic therapeutics.
Furthermore, I think the future of oncology will see a dramatic reduction in cancer
surgeries. My prediction is 25% decrease in the next three
years and a 50% decrease in the next five years.
When I talk to surgeons about this,
first of all, they're in denial,
and then they get angry. So we'll see how that happens over time.
But I think this is a good thing, and I think we can avoid
a lot of cancer surgeries that are life-altering
and brutal going forward. I also think cancer
prevention will override early detection as a means to decrease
the incident of cancer and cancer deaths.
I think there's a lot of hope in early detection,
but even if you look at our best modalities to detect cancer early,
they're not that good.
If you really take a sober look at colonoscopies, for example,
not that good.
I think Pap smears are good, but there you're detecting a pre-cancer, and so it's
slightly different. And so I think that we're going to see a shift as we
learn more about the pre-cancerness
oncogenesis. There's already a big movement to understand this, where cancer
prevention by the use of behavioral modification
or therapeutic intervention will leapfrog cancer early
detection. So akin to cardiology, where we
modify
risk factors that are modifiable.
And so the final thing is, is that I think we're going to see an onslaught of
treatment of cancers with chemical modifications in the genome to create
therapeutic vulnerabilities. And like I said, we have a whole session on that
tomorrow, but there's a variety of other approaches to do this with viruses, for
example, the paint tumors with targets for CAR Ts and
a variety of other things that I think are going to come out of the box soon.
Obviously, I want to thank patients and their families, and especially
philanthropic organizations that allow us to move fast, nimbly, and take
risks.
I'll tell a short story that in
initial grants that we sent to the NIH for circulating tumor DNA
did not score well, and the initial grants for minimal residual disease did not
score well, and the grants for microsatellite instability testing and
therapeutically did not score well.
So without philanthropy, a lot of this work would not happen.
And obviously, the team, many who are here, I thank the Memorial family and the
Johns Hopkins family.
And like I said, these awards are kind of awkward because in
recognizing an individual, you're really recognizing a team.
And this is really reflective of the team and a lot of hard work over the years.
So thank you very much for this honor, and I really appreciate it.
And thanks for staying.
Oh, questions.
I'm so happy I got to attend your presentation.
Thank you.
And congratulations on the award.
And the reason why I'm very happy is actually, well, I'm a second-year HemOnc
fellow at UAMS, University of Arkansas for Medical Sciences,
and
a couple of months ago, I was in the GI clinic with my attending, and I had a
patient who had stage III colon cancer, and the patient
had deficient MMR tumor.
And I was like, "Well, why not do neoadjuvant
immunotherapy at the beginning and spare her surgery?" And the
answer was, "There's no data."
And my question to you is, when the logic is so solid
that immunotherapy works so well in MMR-D
tumors, do we still need Phase III trials in order to
provide the treatment to the patient?
If I was a patient, I would want it to get a neoadjuvant.
Got it.
Why are we not giving it to our patients? Do we still need Phase III trials?
So this is a big debate, right? Because there is a level of uncertainty.
When you're dealing with a
surgery that's life-altering, let's say like in the rectum, in the stomach.
Imagine you lose your stomach or your esophagus or your bladder. Life-altering.
Whenever I talk to colon surgeons, they say, "Give me a napkin and a butter knife,
and I can remove the colon cancer, and it'll be relatively
easy."
But you're right. The data is very strong that with immune checkpoint blockade, you
can eliminate a large percentage of these.
But if you look at the data for colon cancers, two things
happen. One is, yes, you do have a large number of pathological complete responses.
But what we don't have data in is longer-term therapy, and the
lymph nodes can sometimes not be assessed.
And the lymph nodes are areas where this tumor sometimes fail...
this therapy sometimes fails.
The data where we have the best data, they give three doses of immune checkpoint
blockade. That's like nothing. We think we need at least six,
and we've published some papers that you can achieve 100% cure if
you treat for longer.
So I understand the hesitancy there,
especially by the whole medical community, so I think there needs to be more data.
But I think in tumors where the surgery is more brutal, I think
that we do have to take a more aggressive approach.
And certainly in rectal cancer, where we've proven now long-term
that you don't need surgery if you see a complete clinical response,
I think that's a little bit more reassuring. Colon, I'm still a little nervous at.
But you have some of the experts in the world sitting in the room, and you can ask
them as well, so .
Thank you.
Yeah.
Luis.
Oh, yeah.
Hi, Tim Ley, WashU.
Hey.
What a magnificent body of work.
Thank you.
Joel Bershad will be very proud.
A question that we've long struggled with in hematopoietic malignancies, of course,
as you dial up the sensitivity of anything to detect
minimal residual disease, persistent molecular disease, whatever, you
run the risk of over-treatment.
Right.
Because you're
starting to detect cells that can be immunologically monitored,
and in many of these immunogenic tumors, you have the same thing.
So how are you thinking about that with solid tumors, as we can detect one cell
in a million now with precision?
Yeah. So I think-The interesting thing with
solid tumors is that in the tumor-informed approach, and there's two flavors of
minimal disease. There's a tumor-informed approach, and then there's a
tumor-agnostic approach.
The tumor-informed approach, you sequence the tumor, you define those
mutations, and then you look for those mutations in the plasma.
Those first studies were one mutation, and so they weren't perfect.
Now they do 50 to 100 mutations. So the likelihood that
there's a mismatch there or there's a false positive is unbelievably
low.
Sensitivity is still an issue, but I think it's gotten almost as good as it's going
to get, and specificity is unbelievably high.
So I think that given that,
the good news is that I'm not worried about false positives or negatives and
dialing that up and down. I think once we get fancier and
started introducing AI algorithms in that, that's when we're going to see more
noise in over-treatment. But the good news is overall, I think if we
define the circulating tumor DNA population that's positive,
that's going to be much smaller than the patients who actually are going to
recur. So for example, in colon cancer, that's stage III, let's say that
75% of patients are cured by the surgery alone.
25% are likely going to recur. You give adjuvant
therapy, you reduce the likelihood of recurrence by a third.
In that 75%, we would love to find a way to keep chemotherapy away from
them, and that's, I think, where the next phase of this is going to be.
I was really talking about true positives that are immunologically detected and
cleared by immune mop-up after.
Yeah. So you mean not giving them immune checkpoint blockade because we happen to
see them.
Spontaneous regression,
I'm not sure we see that that much in the mismatch repair-deficient population.
I do think you see it in melanoma and kidney cancer.
Mm-hmm.
But it's a good question. I don't think we have a good way of avoiding that.
Yeah.
Luis, thanks. That's a spectacular story.
Thanks, Phil.
I'm curious about when you showed us the recurrence rate after
people who get checkpoint blockade and appear to
be disease-free, and then the recurrence rates
changed dramatically as you moved up from the rectum to the other tissues.
And the question I have is what you think that's about.
Is that the analysis that they're
tumor-free after checkpoint blockade is
just an inadequate survey? Or is it that you think they've set
up essentially a metastatic niche somewhere?
So how many of those recurrences are local, and how many are distal?
Yeah. So they're actually not recurrences, they're incomplete
responses.
So we've set the bar pretty high. That's cure or not cure.
Or not complete response. So those were patients that the tumor
shrank or sometimes didn't and remained there after
therapy. And so it does change throughout the body.
So the rectum's great. The bladder is great.
The prostate, not good. It's very immune tolerant
to these tumors. And
likewise,
the stomach and esophagus weren't as good. The colon's a little bit worse.
So there's a gradient there. And whether that
gradient is
the microbiome or something else
or location, I think that that's something... We do have some clues.
One is that if a tumor is in a barrier tissue, it tends to respond better to immune
checkpoint blockade. So what are barrier tissues?
Lining of the lungs, skin, the GI tract.
If it's not in a barrier tissue, it tends not to respond as well.
So that's all I got.
Go ahead.
Fascinating work.
Thank you.
So early in your talk, you mentioned that for
MMR-deficient,
that you need to accumulate cancer, it takes many
years. Later on, one of your examples of the young patient you
treated, does that young patient have the germline
mutation or it's still somatic mutation of-
You mean the first patient?
The picture you showed a young boy.
Oh, she was, I believe, spontaneous.
That was a sporadic form.
Oh, it's a
somatic mutation?
Yeah, it was a somatic case. It was not a Lynch, I believe.
Okay. So
can you elaborate what do you think why it takes such a
shorter time for the patient actually-
Well, no, I think that tumor was probably born when that patient was an early
teenager.
Oh, okay.
If that makes sense. Yeah. Which opens up a whole
other area, which is these early onset tumors, right, which we didn't touch upon at
all in this. But
if you have an 18-year-old who develops colon
cancer, that tumor was probably born when they were
seven or eight or five years old, right? And so what's going on?
Okay.
Big unknown.
Okay, because I remember many years ago, Dr.
Vogelstein, he
said
for a somatic mutation to happen, occur, then
development of cancer may take 20, 30 years.
Yeah.
So it seems like-
Maybe even in utero.
But sometimes what he says is wrong.
Okay.
Thank you.
Thanks very much. Thank you.